[Music]
on this saturday night help arrives for
flood stricken bc
the military muscle needed for this
emergency plus the damage revealed as
water recedes fueled by anxiety it's
absolutely ridiculous the growing panic
at the pumps
plus the new vaccine mandate for
cross-border truckers
and the protest over a pandemic lockdown
spirals out of control
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we have a devastating development out
of british columbia tonight the death
toll from the catastrophic flooding and
landslides has now risen to four the
rcmp says the bodies of three men have
been recovered from a slide on highway
99 near lillauet that's about three and
a half hours northeast of vancouver
global news has learned one of the
victims is 35 year old mersad hadzik his
wife also died in the slide her body was
recovered on monday they leave behind a
two-year-old girl officials say a fifth
man is still missing but search efforts
have been suspended because of poor
conditions
in southern bc the situation in
abbotsford remains in flux many portions
of the sumas prairie remain underwater
to give you some context this is what a
major roadway looked like in the city in
june of this year and this is what the
same area looked like on friday the
region is home to some of the most
fertile farmland in the country but much
of it remains flooded
this afternoon the city provided an
update on the situation and there's some
positive news our mike armstrong is in
abbotsford tonight with the very latest
mike
well robin there was some good news here
today the city of abbotsford says it was
able to partially open floodgates this
morning that releases some water from
the sumas to the fraser rivers that
takes some pressure off of the dike the
hope is that levels here continue to go
down so that they can open those
floodgates even further and then leave
them that way but basically for the
people we've met here today any good
news is welcome
this was supposed to be a dream home
built just two years ago over the last
few days it's been more of a nightmare
the water got so high monday seven
members of the family had to be rescued
by helicopter that included herget
prewal's 96 year old grandfather this
was something he says that was
unimaginable i thought there was no way
the water was going to get to the house
we built the house three feet higher
than the road over there and you thought
the road was high yeah i thought the
road was high
now you get a feeling for the scale of
this disaster from up high acre after
acre flooded businesses farms homes
hundreds affected
[Applause]
from below you get an idea of how the
water is receding it's gone down
i would guess five or six feet right
here we met jerry ebbers out for a walk
with his grandson surveying the
situation there are still cars and
trucks that were caught in the flooding
and abandoned every morning i wake up
and i look out my windows and look over
the field
and see how much green grass i can see
the abbotsford fire department shared
photos saturday of crews working to
repair a breach in the dike saying there
is progress being made but for people
who've been out of their homes things
are dragging on about 60 evacuees are
staying at this convention center we got
here
monday i think so monday tuesday
wednesday thursday are we saturday yep
okay
alberta blockland's home was flooded but
only the basement she's not sure when
she'll be able to go back even just to
check on things no one can tell her but
she says
it might be soon
getting to a point where i'm like
i'm just moving back in
but then we were told that there's a
fine two thousand dollar fine per person
if they catch it
so and i don't even know if that's true
i mean this is all rumor all rumor
now the reason things have improved is
because the rain has stopped the problem
is the rain is coming back the forecast
calls for
rain starting monday for days and on
some of those days a lot
that is exactly the news people here
don't want to hear robin
mike armstrong in abbotsford bc thanks
mike major roads and highways were taken
out by the floods and mudslides so no
trucks can get in and out that's led to
supply issues and to address that the
province has limited fuel purchases to
30 liters at a time but the conservation
measure is fueling a new problem
global's paul johnson joins us now from
vancouver with the latest on the
rationing paul
hey robin this is a petra can on the
west side of vancouver normally this is
a pretty quiet gas station but as you
can see today they're slammed with the
kind of long lineups they don't
typically see here we've been talking to
drivers throughout the lower mainland
and most of them tell us they get it
this is an extraordinary situation and
they're going to follow the rules but of
course what appears to be happening is
the psychology of scarcity itself pretty
much from the moment bc made this
announcement friday we saw lineups
starting at gas stations throughout the
lower mainland so we're now faced with
the possibility that the most immediate
threat to the gasoline supply here may
not be the delivery problem but on the
demand side with people doing panic
buying here's bc's public safety
minister mike farnworth
if you can avoid travel
work from home or take public transit
for the next 10 days
you will help ensure that we have the
fuel and access and means to keep
responding as we need to as soon as you
start telling people to stop buying gas
they're going to start panic buying
making a lot worse and they're obviously
there's going to be absolutely nothing
it's going to be there same as all the
food is going to be in the stores and
it's embarrassing to see people hoarding
everything and especially in this time
when you know
so just to recap what the situation is
for drivers here in this part of british
columbia right now limited to 30 liters
per fill up this is an honor system we
don't have the police out at gas
stations commercial and emergency
vehicles of course are exempt they hope
that this will be normalized and they
can drop this by december 1st but of
course some of the big unknowns how do
they restore the fuel supply
infrastructure the single biggest
component that we've lost is the trans
mountain pipeline which delivers oil
from alberta they're expecting they may
get that up and running by the end of
next week but already they're pointing
out this is the longest shutdown in that
pipeline in its 70-year history
robin paul johnson in vancouver thanks
paul
to help ease the gas shortage the bc
government is calling on ottawa to
change its pcr testing requirements
earlier than planned
it's going to be done anywhere on the
30th of november so why not do it now
if approved by the federal government
the move would allow people in the lower
mainland to cross the border and fill up
like pre-coveted times as of november
30th fully vaccinated canadians will be
able to go back and forth for short
trips without needing a costly pcr test
the federal government says american
visitors will still need a pcr test and
there's a new mandate for truckers
considered essential workers who go back
and forth over the border they'll have
to be vaccinated as david aiken reports
this patchwork of rules has hurt the
travel industry
every day 30 000 trucks roll across the
canada u.s border bringing food and
supplies crucial to feeding both
countries and keeping north america's
economy moving for that reason truck
drivers were deemed essential workers
exempt from public health rules when it
comes to travel but that exemption ends
january the 15th which means truck
drivers like all other travelers will
have to be fully vaccinated and in an
industry already short some eighteen
thousand drivers ottawa's vaccine
mandate will make things worse anywhere
between ten and twenty percent
of of the hundred and twenty thousand
truck drivers canadian truck drivers
that cross into the united states and
canada border
will exit the industry
meanwhile the airline industry is upset
ottawa did not scrap the requirement for
molecular tests for all inbound
travelers only fully vaccinated
canadians out of the country for less
than three days will be exempt from that
testing requirement
by only focusing on short trips and
canadian travelers government has taken
a piecemeal approach that is not
justified nor based on science the
national airlines council of canada said
in a statement to our knowledge no other
country in the world has adopted such a
narrow approach
when parliament resumes next week the
trudeau government can expect to hear
about that from the opposition scrapping
the pcr test is uh is where we need to
go we need to do it for our economy we
need to do it to get in line with uh
with our allies but some experts think
the incremental approach to rule changes
for travelers is the right one i think
that this signals what we all hope is
one more step towards normalcy
and i think that doing it in a
progressive stepwise manner is the way
to go for now the government has
committed only to a review of the rules
in the weeks ahead david aiken global
news ottawa
the rising number of infections in
europe has led to some governments
imposing new restrictions to curb the
spread of cova-19 in the netherlands
police and protesters faced off
overnight as demonstrations against a
new partial lockdown turned violent
[Applause]
rotterdam's mayor called it an orgy of
violence as people in the city streets
fought with police and torched cars
authorities used water cannons and fired
warning shots to push the crowds back
the new restrictions will be in place
for three weeks and see limits put on
gatherings in homes and the operation of
non-essential businesses this week the
dutch government recorded its highest
single day increase of new infections
there were angry demonstrations across
the united states last night a show of
outrage over the acquittal of kyle
rittenhouse a jury found the 18 year old
not guilty of murdering the two men he
shot last year during an anti-racism
protest in kenosha wisconsin as jennifer
johnson reports rittenhouse may have
been freed but he could still face more
legal action
overnight a small group of protesters
remained outside the kenosha wisconsin
courthouse where hours before 18 year
old kyle rittenhouse was acquitted of
five charges including intentional
homicide we the jury find the defendant
kyle h rittenhouse not guilty in
brooklyn new york a much louder crowd
denounced the verdict by allowing
greenhouse to walk away
this entire country this government has
slapped us all in the face
in august 2020 rittenhouse fatally
gunned down two men joseph rosenbaum and
anthony huber and wounded a third during
a protest in kenosha over the shooting
of a black man jacob blake by a white
police officer rittenhouse testified he
shot the men in self-defense the verdict
is polarizing parts of the country he
did not come up here to save lives
he came up here to take lives he said
that before he got here and that's
exactly what he did i feel like they
made the right choice you know it was it
was simple self-defense
president biden said the jury's verdict
left him angry and concerned but it must
be accepted but his vice president had a
much stronger reaction the verdict
really speaks for itself
as many of you know i've spent a
majority of my career working to make
the criminal justice system
more equitable and clearly there's a lot
more work to do rittenhouse's future is
now very much in question he can still
face a civil lawsuit by the plaintiff's
families where the burden of proof is
much easier there is precedent in a
famous civil lawsuit the loved ones of
nicole brown and ron goldman were
awarded a 33.5 million judgment against
o.j simpson after he was acquitted of
their murders
even if rittenhouse doesn't have any
money it could be a moral victory for
the families who were shocked by the
jury's decision in this case it feels
like the victims lives don't matter in
the meantime rittenhouse's attorney says
the teenager will likely move away from
the area saying it's too dangerous for
him to stay there
jennifer johnson global news washington
coming up the one-on-one with the
conservative leader a global news
exclusive
conservative leader erin o'toole is
standing his ground following a threat
to his leadership this week a senator
from his own party launched a petition
calling for a review of his election
performance on the west block o'toole
speaks exclusively with our mercedes
stevenson about his future and divisions
within his party mercedes
robin earlier this week in ottawa aaron
o'toole held a caucus retreat where he
faced off with mps and senators who are
unhappy with his performance and the
centrist direction he's taking the party
in in his first interview with network
television since the election aaron
o'toole told the west block he is
confident that he has the support of
caucus even after senator denise batters
publicly attacked o'toole and o'toole
booted her from caucus we had the best
retreat best caucus meetings we've had
in my full year as leader mercedes we're
united on standing up for canadians when
parliament returns when someone fights
against their own team doesn't actually
follow the will of the team we have
caucus meetings that are are always
lively they have been since i came here
nine years ago as a back venture but
those conversations are held indoors we
respect one another and the situation
with one of our senators she made a
decision to essentially leave the team
herself senate conservatives have defied
o'toole's position though and are
keeping batters in their caucus aaron
o'toole also told the west block that
all conservative mps are now fully
vaccinated or have received medical
exemptions and they will be in the house
of commons when parliament returns on
monday the news comes after the
conservative leader had promised to
challenge a vaccine mandate requiring
all mps to be doubly vaccinated in order
to enter the house of commons
well we've said for many months mercedes
that
we when we return to parliament and
that's coming now this week we will be
ready to serve and that all the mps will
be vaccinated or will have
a medical exemption
following the rules we'll have more
tomorrow on the west block robin
mercedes stephenson in ottawa thanks
mercedes and as mercedes mentioned you
can watch the full interview with
o'toole tomorrow on the west block right
here on global
a senator from ontario has passed away
after being treated for copin 19. jose
jorge niling was admitted to a sudbury
hospital in october but was discharged
last week to recover at home she was
fully vaccinated though she had an
autoimmune condition affecting her lungs
making her particularly vulnerable to
the virus foreign had been a member of
the independent senate group since 2018.
she was 56.
still ahead a country that broke away
from the former yugoslavia now
threatened with its own breakup
there are mounting concerns about peace
and stability in bosnia and herzegovina
the balkan nation's long-standing power
sharing deal is at risk of crumbling it
was put in place 26 years ago to end the
brutal ethnic war that claimed tens of
thousands of lives as redmond shannon
explains the leader of the country's
serbian region has threatened to split
up key institutions including the army
seventy-eight-year-old haira chatic died
this month after spending a quarter of a
century looking for her murdered son
nihad
she never found him
he was among more than 8 000 muslim men
and boys killed in the srebrenica
genocide carried out by the bosnian serb
army during the bosnian war in the 90s
now there are fears such ethnic tensions
could break this fragile young nation
apart as part of the 1995 dayton accord
bosnia and herzegovina is made up of a
loose union of two regions the
federation of bosnia and herzegovina
which is mostly bosniak muslims and
ethnic croats and the republican serbs
which is mostly ethnic serbs
the country's presidency rotates between
the three groups
[Music]
the serbian leader milorad dodeck has
recently threatened to pull out of state
institutions including potentially
splitting the army in two his rhetoric
leaves the scars and people are already
scared
especially those who are old enough to
remember the 90s we all feel
re-traumatized
says large-scale violence is unlikely
but people in ethnic enclaves are
feeling under threat dodic claims that
everything he does uh is an act of
retaliation uh to the former high
representative of the international
community valentin insco who recently
left the role used the job's power to
make genocide denial a crime the high
representative was placed in bosnia as
part of the peace deal
they're appointed by the west something
russia an ally of serbia and serbs is
unhappy
with from dayton
the incumbent christian schmidt says
dodec's moves are part of a slow erosion
of the dayton accord kurt bessiner is a
former advisor to the representative's
office we have more tools to deal with
this kind of challenge in bosnia than we
do anywhere else on earth and yet we're
still on the back foot so that signifies
a real policy humiliation and failure
dodec says threats of u.s sanctions
don't scare him likely betting the west
has bigger problems to deal with adding
to the tensions are efforts by croat
nationalists to reform the electoral
system potential changes that could edge
out more moderate parties in the small
but diverse country redmond shannon
global news london
up next high inflation and low interest
rates the consequences for consumers
life is getting more expensive and we
know you already know that well
statistics canada is validating your
concerns the latest inflation snapshot
for october reveals the cost of living
is up 4.7
in the past year and interest rates are
low as ann gaviola reports that
combination is not good for your bank
account
[Music]
the last time inflation was this hot was
back in february 2003 when avril lavigne
topped the charts now a big driver the
cost of living this time around was gas
prices at the pumps up more than 40
percent since october 2020 but that's
not all just about everything is more
expensive food shelter cars current
combination of high inflation and low
interest rates is a double whammy for
household budgets high inflation eats
away at your purchasing power while your
money hardly earns anything in your
savings account now with stock markets
including the tsx regularly breaking
records and the cryptocurrency market
making headlines for crossing new
heights you may be tempted to redirect
your cash
the historical pace of inflation for the
past century is about three percent
annually now with the tsx returning 9.3
percent between 1960 and 2020 that's one
way to guard against inflation but
personal finance expert bridget casey
says not to dip into your emergency fund
even if it's barely earning any interest
in your savings account
anything that's a short-term goal so
less than two years should absolutely be
totally in cash instead shop around to
find a higher interest no fee savings
account from an online only bank or
credit union but leave your rainy day
fund alone the bank of canada has
signaled it could raise its key lending
rates as early as this spring or summer
but portfolio manager ben felix says
this isn't the time to be totally
revamping your investment mix we don't
know where inflation is going to go but
as of now i wouldn't i wouldn't be
rushing to increase risk in a portfolio
to combat um
higher unexpected inflation because we
can't expect that i think we have to
wait and see what happens
some view cryptocurrency is a hedge
against inflation but felix doesn't buy
it the reality is the crypto is
extremely volatile and something that
volatile it's really tricky to call it a
hedge the same thing is true with
gold financial experts recommend taking
a good hard look at your bank and
investment fees those can be reduced
sometimes it's just a matter of a simple
phone call to negotiate that's probably
one of the best things that you can do
for your finances in the meantime ann
gaviola global news toronto
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm robin gill tonight
your canada is the view from hudson bay
mountain above smithers british columbia
we'd love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching jeff semple will
be at the anchor desk tomorrow have a
great night
[Music]
[Music]